just the other day I was doing the
little netflix and chill' with bear and
what do I find cells at work I promised
that I would do a review of this
probably like a year and a half ago and
I sort of forgot about this but now that
it's on Netflix I have no excuse so I
popped it on season one episode one is
right here it's called pneumococcus I'm
ready let's get started
noona can you uh
yes Santa Ana to commence a voltage gain
connected
[Music]
[Music]
shake it kill him Abu Radi yo Kefka
mechanic I get shaky Junkanoo they
certainly Sampath ah so that's it it so
funny
alright so I'm already starting to piece
it together from the intro here that
each one of these characters represents
the cells and each one of these
characters is like an employee or has
some sort of job and if they're wearing
red their red blood cells which it just
gave it a great explanation that they
carry oxygen and carbon dioxide
throughout the body the fact that
they're doing it in packages is even
funnier because that has a medical
meaning
so the vascular endothelial cells are
the cells that line your blood vessels
if they get injured guess what happens
bleeding oh that was bloodier than I
expected the irony of this though is
that there's a red blood cell person
there and they're killing the germ and
the germ is bleeding red blood cells
Juuko choo-choo Cola you okay so this is
interesting because this gentleman here
is a white blood cell part of the
neutrophil division means that he's
attacking a bacteria because neutrophils
primarily work against bacteria don't
know what you won one for sixes maybe
that's his code name white blood cells
and red blood cells exist within your
circulation at all times you need both
to function the red blood cells
obviously the most important for the
oxygen the white blood cells are part of
your immune system
in fact when I do something known as a
CBC which is a blood test that's a
complete blood count the two main
numbers that we read on there are the
hemoglobin and the white blood cell
count if I'm looking to see if you have
an infection that white blood cell count
number can be low or high that's
important to know
I'm not gonna lie these bacteria look
pretty badass I don't know why she's so
lost once the heart pumps you should be
able to just go into one direction that
it pumps this is really funny because
co2 is carbon dioxide and when you
deliver it back to the lungs your body
exhales it which is a form of waste
[Music]
that's true this is very accurate that
strep pneumo is one of the most common
bacteria for respiratory infections and
sometimes ear infections actually in
children we give the pneumococcal
vaccine in order to decrease the rates
of infection and if they are to get
infected hopefully it's a less severe
infection we also give the same vaccines
to those who are over the age of 65 in
some cases also for that same purpose
decreases rates of pneumonia hi you know
Megan a cockatiel kyousuke-shi no three
marathi moushmi hi can you eat a slice
you take any couldn't figure you he's
talking about meningitis that's an
infection of the meninges which surround
the brain that's the padding that
surrounds the brain obviously very
dangerous not only because of infection
in the brain is not a good idea but also
because that swelling causes increased
pressure also quite dangerous these
consider this you will see you tomorrow
email kono karada make you've not taken
Yogananda la única she would I wonder
why this body is immunocompromised
immuno compromised meaning that their
immune system is not functioning well
this usually happens as a result of a
medication that they're taking other
illnesses that they have for example
those who have HIV or AIDS
those are immunodeficient States meaning
that they're immunocompromised to
infections very commonly if someone's
getting an organ transplant they take
medications to make them immuno
compromised there's all sorts of
situations for that but I wonder which
one they're using here it's funny
they're using almost like the lack of
policing resources as a representation
from you know compromised I love that
[Applause]
[Music]
platelets are so cute in this which is
kind of funny because platelets are
supposed to be big platelets are the
white blood cells that actually clump
and start the clotting process they
actually clump together and start the
clotting process so if you ever get a
cut its your platelets that are
responsible for stopping the bleed oh
the killer T cells are here the immune
mediated responses are coming through
the lymphatic vessel
I love that this is so much
pathophysiology right now this is like
above my paygrade right now
the fact that pneumococcal bacteria are
hemolytic in nature that they're gonna
go after the red blood cells is
something I haven't studied in ages this
is amazing so capillaries are so thin
that they only allow a single stream of
red blood cells through in order to have
diffusion between them and the alveoli I
have a feeling she's gonna run into him
[Music]
oh no he got a little cuckoo mother hot
comb dickly oh no the much blood shall
help them get there all the capsule
blocked in
he's an encapsulated bacteria cool look
so returning our erupting I'm gonna make
a little prediction right now that all
three of these are gonna get coughed out
in the mucus toxin yeah
you have to get pumped out this means
he's about to get sneezed out
platelets are just by you by you Kindle
you know it's funny
germs actually have hang time so when
you sneeze and they're outside of your
body they actually can hang around in
the air so you can walk into a room that
someone sneezed in they're not in there
anymore you could still get sick are we
getting a Grey's Anatomy moment inside
cells at work come on now MA
well not a sick idea how that I dunno
each guys now I understand why you guys
have been pushing me to watch this it's
well done
it's entertaining it's funny for nerds
like myself who love learning about the
human body and refreshing some of their
knowledge from medical school in the in
college days this is brilliant it's
creative you gotta give them that if you
want me to watch another episode of
these maybe you can recommend like the
best episode and I can watch that one as
you know I love watching all sorts of TV
shows and dramas and all that stuff
in fact I put a special playlist
together for you right here right not
right here right here click on that bad
boy we're gonna watch it together while
staying happy and healthy where's bear
[Music]